so you've talked a lot about the mental
illness and depressed and anxious
population in the trans Community but
you don't talk about the happy people in
the trans community and how these
preventative measures of let's say like
puberty and the surgeries that go for
gender affirmation and how these are
life-changing and life-saving I know
many people how do you know oh okay one
second if I can finish my conversation
um
many people in my life have had these
interventions made and it's saved their
lives I can list dozens of people in my
life
so what do you have to say for you can
you can list dozens of people who had
surgeries and drugs as children would be
dead today if they hadn't I'm sorry let
me rephrase that dozens of people who
have had interventions including gender
affirming let's say therapies
um yes hormones surgeries that have made
their lives better I'm not saying it
didn't force them to commit suicide but
it made their lives better what do you
have to say for the happy trans
community
uh
I guess I would I would throw back at
you first because the burden of proof is
on you on this one and I'll explain why
the burden of proof is on you because as
I went over in the talk
um for thousands of years human beings
existed and there was no such thing as
trying to medically transition
people into another gender
and as far as we know there was no
suicide epidemic because of it
and then in the last few years people
like yourself have come along and said
we desperately need to do this or people
will be in Despair and they might kill
themselves so you are making a claim
that contradicts
Common Sense Science Biology also the
entire experience of the whole history
of human race and so what that means is
that the burden of proof is on you to
support it and so I'm going to ask you
you said that people need this stuff so
they can live happier lives and
potentially it'd be life-saving you said
even
aside from your anecdotes of your
friends who told you so
how do you know that okay so
um thinking back to when I was 16 in an
anatomy class when I learned that
um transgender people tend to have the
brain structure that confirms their
identity that they identify with and you
can look that up I will look that up
yeah
we'll find it yeah it's not a fact it's
not a fact should we all pull out Google
really quick look
um so you're saying a trans man has the
brain of a woman
no
I'm saying that a trans man who
identifies as a man will tend to have
similar brain structure that a CIS man
would
and where did you get that from
look it up I it's literally I I'm
telling you I learned it from my anatomy
class when I was 16 and I looked up the
fact before I walked up here because I
knew that you'd ask okay
um
that's
not true but it also doesn't answer the
question so let's try to stay focused on
one
false claim at a time if we can't we
might get bogged down okay so you said
you actually started by saying that
blocking puberty
which is chemical castration of a child
just just one example yeah is
life-saving it can be how do you know
because there are children who have been
suicidal that have had these
interventions made what children how do
you know and how many children have had
that done
me personally I haven't met enough trans
children to answer that question okay
but I know you are making research
exists
you're making this statement you're
stating it as a fact in front of all
these people there must be a reason it
must be something that you encountered
that that led you to this
rather radical conclusion that to save a
child's life you have to chemically
castrate them
okay well that is what you just said the
drugs we give to kids for for puberty
blockers so-called Purity blockers
originally are cancer drugs used to
treat prostate cancer they're also used
to chemically castrate sex offenders and
child rapists now we give them to
physically healthy kids you're saying
that we need to do that or they will die
and so one last time I'm going to ask
you what evidence do you have of that
remarkable claim
I don't think I claimed that every child
would benefit from that no I didn't say
you did and okay
you said puberty blockers are
life-saving whatever they can be
um so the evidence is the encounters
with patients who have had these
procedures done and it has saved their I
don't want to say it saved their lives
but it has made their lives better I
can't confirm whether or not they're
alive right this second
but there are children that it has
helped so what do you have to say for
the happy trans Community who has
benefited from these procedures that's
my question is that your entire question
is built on a whole stack of false
premises that you that you can't begin
to even remotely defend so I I it's it
is a it's a faulty question from the
start I I reject your premise I I
absolutely reject that there are any
kids who need to be chemically castrated
in order to be happy okay okay let's
I reject that
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]